تعود لعبةُ التصريحاتِ السياسية بشأن مصيرِ الرئيس السوري بشار الأسد إلى الواجهة.. فحينا لا مكان له وحينا يبقى في منصبِهِ مع شروط وآخرُ مبهمٌ لا وضوح فيه..
جديدُ هذا المسلسل.. تأكيدُ وزير الخارجية الفرنسي لوران فابيوس أن رحيلَ الأسد ليس شرطا للبدءِ بعمليةِ انتقال سياسي في سوريا لكن يجب أن تكون هناك ضماناتٌ مستقبلية.. كلامُ فابيوس سبقته تصريحاتُ نظيره الأمريكي جون كيري
الذي بدوره تحدثَ عن إمكانيةِ تعاونِ القواتِ الحكومية السورية مع المجموعاتِ المسلحة للقضاء على تنظيم داعش في إطار حل سياسي انتقالي.. لكنه وبالرغم من إشارتِهِ إلى صعوبةِ تحقيقِ هذه الغاية فإن مراقبين اعتبروا ذلك انعطافةً جديدة في الموقفِ الأمريكي..
تطوراتٌ تأتي قبيلَ انعقادِ مؤتمر الرياض الأسبوع المقبل بحضورِ شخصياتٍ تمثل للمرةِ الأولى أطيافا مختلفة من المعارضة السورية إضافة إلى فصائلَ مسلحةٍ سيجلسون حولَ طاولةٍ واحدة في محاولةٍ للوصول إلى نقطتين أساسيتين..
الاتفاقُ على مرحلة انتقالية وشكلِ البلاد السياسي في سوريا بسياسة واضحة وموحدة
تشكيلُ قائمةٍ موحدة للمعارضة تكون كفيلةً بمحاورة وفد الحكومة في نيويورك
أما عن الحاضرين فقد وجهَت السعوديةُ دعواتٍ إلى تياراتٍ معارضة كالائتلاف السوري ومؤتمِر القاهرة وهيئةِ التنسيق الوطنية كذلك وجهَت دعواتٍ إلى ممثلين عما يسمى جيشَ الإسلام بقيادة زهران علوش والجبهةَ الجنوبية وحركةَ أحرار الشام أيضا.. وهي فصائلُ مقاتلة..
فيما يتغيبُ عن هذا المؤتمر الثقلُ الكردي بشقيه السياسي (حزب الاتحاد الديموقراطي) والعسكري المتمثل بذراعِهِ الضاربة وحدات حماية الشعب.. ووصفَ رئيسُ الاتحاد الديموقراطي صالح مسلم ذلك بالأمرِ المعيب..
موسكو التي تؤكدُ أن مصيرَ الأسد هو من صلاحياتِ الشعب السوري وحدَه دعَت الرياض إلى عدمِ استثناء أحد في المؤتمر من دون عواملَ انتقائية.. كما شددَ وزيرُ الخارجية الروسي سيرغي لافروف على أهميةِ الفصل
بين الإرهابيين ومن تعاون معهم وبين المعارضةِ المعتدلة.. سوريون في المنفى ومنفيون في أرضِ الوطن ينتظرون أيَّ بارقةِ أمل تعيد ما بقي منهم لممارسةِ حقه الطبيعي بالحياة.